now i want to turn to sean ryder he's
been waiting patiently sean i want to
talk to you
i want to talk to you uh not about those
things you'd be pleased i want to talk
to you about uh rock festivals we saw
the return of glastonbury and i want to
say although i would literally rather go
to hell and back than actually go to
glastonbury and sit in a stinking tent
surrounded by stinking people for four
days uh i gotta say i i did enjoy
watching it on tv i love the spectacle i
love the huge crowds uh and what was
interesting to me was a lot of the
biggest stars of the festival
were the old rockers paul mccartney
diana ross another let's take a look at
a clip of two of them
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now what was your reaction sean first of
all to the return of festivals do you
like festivals and secondly to makker
and diana ross
well you know what i was just listening
to that there right and it's live right
okay so you know you don't get the sound
checks you're going to get a normal show
everything's really hurted you know
including for the headline acts but what
i just did then sounded brilliant you
know i mean i've heard you know bits of
chatter about out a key and all that lot
but to me
please i mean i might be off me not
sport or not i don't think you're off
your mouth but you might need you you
might need your ears cleaned out because
i thought this i watched the whole of
paul mccartney set and the whole of
diana ross is set i thought mccartney
was magnificent i thought that was
honestly one of the greatest questions
shows i've ever seen but i also thought
he was brilliantly judicious absolutely
yeah he was brilliant in the selection
of the songs he chose to sing
she understands the limitation of his
voice and i thought he got away with it
however diana ross i'm really sorry but
she sounded like a bunch of drowning
cats
what were you listening to
well
well i'm not going to start slagging
diana off am i you know at the end of
the day right she's got to go on there
and do a live show obviously and you
know with a limited sound check and
you know oh good honor i mean at the end
of the day diana can sing you know she
can't i mean he it's really tough going
out and and doing a show at glasgow
belly you know you don't she's not going
to get the best sound check she really
isn't so let me ask you a shout out
please
what was interesting to me diana ross
performed at the she was the the sort of
final act of the platinum jubilee the
queen yeah and she sounded fantastic but
it obviously because she was auto-tuned
right they helped her why couldn't they
do that at glastonbury so that you
actually preserve her dignity a bit
better
because he's no time to do that pierce
he really isn't you know i mean i don't
know how many axes on before her or how
many axes on after her but you really
haven't got the time to do what they did
when she was going out performing for
the queen and uh and all that gang
i'm gonna i'm really not gonna sit here
and start slagging her off i don't know
i don't see he's not anymore don't get
me wrong i love diana ross and i think
she's one of the greatest singers in
history it's just interesting to me in
the last week you've seen elton john in
england you see mick jagger doing it
with the stones paul mccartney and diana
ross i've got to say you know elton
he sort of gets away with it because
he's lowered the range of his singing
mick jagger was never that great a
singer he's a brilliant performer and
seems to maintain the same level of
reasonably immediate but he's not a
great singer mick jagger isn't he
doesn't say that meat jagger is not a
great brilliant singer he's the best
belle wingding ringer going in the world
no he's a great he's a great hit winner
he's earned his rights he's a brilliant
performer but well he is yeah he would
never compare him to a singer like
freddie mercury would you he's not a
great singer
i i i i'd rate him better than freddie
mercury for what mick does you know i
mean you know freddie's going out there
doing what freddie does and mick's going
out there doing what mick does yeah and
they're both genius and they're just
both incredible performers and brilliant
bell ringers both of them
i do love a brilliant bell ringer sean
you're on fire stay there a short break
and we'll be back after the break with
my sensational pierce patch all
performing at the top of the game i have
to say age cannot wither them they'll
custom stale their infinite variety
pierce pack is still with me so adam
you've been fulminating there in the
break about my comments about well you
thought you think mick jagger is a good
singer for one which is a ludicrous
position
i do think he's very good singer i'm
actually going to the stones next
weekend i mean they're brilliant
he's never been a great singer jagger i
think he has i mean i think he he could
do falsetto what he can't do anymore is
the full set of the sort of stuff he did
on angie another thing and dinah ross
yeah well listen
you're completely wrong about
glastonbury i mean the one who's really
lost his voice is paul mccartney no i
know i don't know i know he's a national
treasure no he doesn't bet he can sing
better everyone loves singing along to
hey jude and all that but if you
actually listen to it
his voice is gone diana ross's voice i
felt is also going but there's more to
it
than uh there isn't i think what's going
on
i mean diana ross didn't have to bring
on boxing gulshan um
and springsteen to back her up no but
that was a good idea if
mccartney played 35 songs in three years
we all heard what we just heard yeah
i'm sorry diana ross
no the thing is i i genuinely think
because i don't if you remember that
performance by mariah carey in new york
like years ago and that was god awful
yeah obviously the older you get the
more strain your vocals are i think she
should have chosen like some ballads
that are bit slower they didn't have as
much noise because still want to play
all the big
as objectively as an artistic
performance because you know he's second
only to david attenborough in terms of
sort of nationalism and i think he's he
deservedly so let me go back to sean
ryder sean
[Music]
sean i want to get your take not on that
anymore no you lot in that studio piece
you're all off your nuts
off your nuts i mean if you put diana
ross right in a studio in a controlled
environment in a studio not the wild
west of glastonbury
right winging it put diana in the studio
where she's like pavarotti and
controlled and can hear everything
perfectly then diana will come up with
the guts it's like throwing anyone down
sean
sean i hesitate to lecture you about
singing although i have had my own
moments in front of a microphone well
i'm not i'm not a singer pierce neither
is bob dylan i'm you know at the end of
the day if i came along now and bob
dylan came along now we will be called
rappers because we don't technically
sing like pavarotti you know so there's
a whole different thing going on you
know what i mean i mean jagger does what
jagger does and he gets over every lyric
and and he keeps key and don't get me
wrong
don't get me wrong
mick jagger is a great rock star
arguably in my opinion the greatest rock
star there's been mccartney to me is the
greatest pop star diana ross was the
female kind of equivalent of fantastic
with the supremes brilliant solo but
sadly as we heard at glastonbury her
voice is just no longer strong enough to
carry a show like that it just it just
isn't
well i'm not having that place i'm not
i'm not having that yeah
well that's just me
frankly it's the young ones against the
old ones
she had a bad night yeah but about i
don't think she had a bad night i really
don't know
just one thing just because of you
one thing one thing though
i mean your voice does change as you get
older doesn't it and and you know my
position is if all of them hung up their
microphone right now i wouldn't regard
it as a tragedy well i i actually
thought the mccarthy sacrilege for paul
mccartney aged 80 to do that show he did
last night nearly three hours on i just
thought was magical absolutely magical i
really did and i think your denigration
of this godlike figure is actually
borderline sacrilege i do uh but i
didn't think it was great i mean sean
when you play
what does denigration mean
to me
what does denigration it means to talk
something down you know i mean we're
buddies and i don't even know what
you mean
you know you know sean i was telling
somebody earlier about our little
escapade with ronnie biggs in rio it
brought back very fond memories
oh yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
let's just say one minute let's just say
my melons got well and truly twisted by
you lot
they got twisted they certainly did food
you got twisted sean and even
have you ever eaten stinging nettles
have i ever eaten eaten stinky nails
singing i don't think so right so i've
got a plate for this i have a plate full
of
they're repellent things they look
disgusting they taste even worse and
they actually sting you so the very last
thing you should ever do obviously is
eat them and yet in a part of britain
right now that's what they're doing
yeah over the weekend there was the
world stinging nettle eating
championship at the dorset nectar cider
farm on saturday you can see them all
chowing look at these lunatics all
munching on stinging nettles just to
remind you look awful taste even worse
and actually put toxic materials into
your stomach here are the winners uh
lindy rogers was the queen of netherland
again she's
won it before 42 feet of steel nettles
she consumed while a man known as nile
beat off his rivals by eating 54 feet of
nettles sean ryder
what do you think of that
i think that's wild
[Laughter]
do you know what i actually agree i
actually agree you know to me is i
started off thinking it was nuts and
then i thought actually it's a fantastic
example of great british eccentricity
there's nowhere else in the world but
they would have a british stinging
nettle competition and the fact that we
have people mad enough in this country
to eat 50 feet of this stuff makes me
proud to be british panel are we in
agreement
[Music]
yes yes that we are
why are they stinging you i don't know
because i'm impervious to stinging shawl
rider final word are you proud to be
british with these people
oh yeah i'm well proud to be brick yeah
of course yeah yeah
sure it's brilliant to have you as well
it's brilliant to have you and i look
forward to having a stinging nettle
eating competition with you one day soon
we've done pretty much everything else
together great to see you